doit d'abord merci à thierry ardisson
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui plus de 30
ans presque 30 ans de télévision
alors évidemment passer de l'interviewer
à l'interviewer
c'est pas forcément l'exercice le plus
facile vous allez pouvoir lui poser des
questions à différents moments je vous
dirai quand je voudrais commencer par
vous lire un extrait de la préface d'un
livre qui s'appelle fugue en gros bémol
là tout de suite vous dit [ __ ] il est
chiant mais vous allez voir pourquoi
l'auteur s'auto interview il pose la
question donc et il répond question
êtes-vous catholique
réponse je crois en dieu et je suis
partisan d'une religion que je décrirais
peut-être plus tard dans un livre qui
cette question plus tard
que comptez vous faire réponse du
journalisme et écrire toujours écrire
quand on n'y touche c'est comme la
drogue
question est ce que vous lisez beaucoup
réponse quand je vais en classe oui les
pendant les vacances je préfère regarder
la télé cette fausse interview ce livre
qui commence par ce jeu de questions
réponses entre un auteur et un
journaliste imaginaire c'est signé
thierry ardisson il avait 14 ans et demi
ça ne s'invente pas on a même le vocable
dans il est resté en normandie je crois
inventons dont il ya eu cette expérience
au dj whisky à gogo mais ça on n'en
parlera pas ce soir et thierry ardisson
quitte sa famille part à paris avec 50
francs en poche
et puis là il ya toute cette histoire
que vous connaissez peut-être jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à la télévision je voulais
commencer cette master class par la
première chose qui pour moi très
important dans l'est dans l'art de
l'interview à la thierry ardisson c'est
la publicité en réalité thierry tu n'es
pas journaliste je suis pas du tout
journalistes n'ont jamais fait d'études
de journalisme j'ai j'ai fait une
licence d'anglais que j'ai même pas
terminé je suis pas journaliste j'ai pas
de carte de journaliste mais j'ai
l'esprit journalistique c'est à dire sur
la curiosité des journalistes aient le
culot qu'il faut avoir quand on veut
être
j'imagine un bon journaliste donc ton
métier c'est leur métier ses concepteurs
dans la publicité
j'ai appris à trouver des concepts
s'appuie si c'est un métier très
difficile parce que finalement on vous
demande de dire que l'autre vite elle
sait mieux que l'eau d'evian en fait
c'est pas vrai évidemment mais on est
payé pour dire que pour expliquer
pourquoi donc c'est un métier qui est
uniquement basée sur le concept et sur
la forme
après quelques années de publicité j'ai
compris qu'ils avaient pas de quoi
remplir une vie c'est un métier
passionnant ou très jeunes on m'avait
donné de l'argent pour faire des
affiches des films des messages radio
des annonces presse
mais voilà la finalité de la pub c'est
de vendre des produits
donc au bout d'un moment on se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est toute cette énergie
ce temps que je dépense pour vendre des
produits en revanche donc j'en suis
parti mais en revanche que j'avais
appris dans la publicité c'est à dire le
sens du concept
le soin du détail dans la forme m'a aidé
dans tout ce que j'ai fait par la suite
que ce soit des journaux des livres des
émissions de télé maintenant des films
ou des séries et ça a été pour moi
en fait ma grande école ça a été la
publicité le premier concept c'était
descente de police d'abord de
rock'n'folk et ensuite pour tf1 en en 85
on a fait une série dans rock et folk
pas si vous connaissez rock et folk
à l'époque sa seconde est pas mal c'est
un journal de rock un magazine de rock
et on leur a proposé une série ou en
fait le principe c'était de temps de
transformer l'interview en
interrogatoire c'est à dire qu'en fait
on
mon copain et moi nous on était 2 on
était des flics quand on a interviewé
les stars les interviewés comme des
flics voilà ça s'appelait décembre de
police et ça a eu beaucoup de succès
parce qu'en plus dans un journal comme
rock et folk est un journal disons de
rock de rap à l'époque de folk
évidemment nous on interviewe et dalida
ils montrent en fait que des gens qui
avaient rien à voir quoi et en plus la
façon de les questionner était tout à
fait nouvelle
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire ah ben
je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes ici
qu'en fait quand on quand on cherche des
idées c'est une parenthèse d'une
digression quand on cherche des idées il
faut toujours se dire est ce que je suis
dans la différence et pas dans la
surenchère
je donne un exemple par exemple quand
j'ai commencé la pub
il y avait une campagne de pub à
l'époque existent et que c'est pour le
petit fromage kiri le fromage des
gastronomes en culottes courtes
il fallait trouver autre chose ça avait
déjà été fait donc la surenchère soir
était de faire des gastronomes avec des
culottes encore plus courte et la
différence ça a été de dire chaque fois
que votre enfant mange à une portion du
fromage en question qui s'appelait samus
c'est comme s'ils vivaient un verre de
lait et nous on avait joué que les
descendait pour le gosse manger tout ça
pour vous expliquer le l'importance de
la différence donc dans rock et folk ou
rock et folk
on a mis des gens qu'on voyait jamais
dans rock et folk dalida et on l'a
interviewé d'une façon différente qui
fait que tf1 a vu ça et m'a dit est ce
que tu peux faire la même chose à la
télévision voilà donc c'était ma
première émission de télévision ça a
duré six numéros parce qu'au bout de six
numéros s'est fait virer par le csa de
l'époque qui trouvais ça trop violente
vous allez comprendre pourquoi 4 octobre
85 descente de police donc avec yves
simon vous regarde vous propose de
passer un mois au lit désert je marchais
ou le bel niki les valets de carhaix
lequel tu choisis radeau de la méduse
non non c'est un peu moins une question
qui aurait précis majorettes ont marché
où le pèlerin un mois de vie dr aventure
qu'est l'île n'importe quelle île de
tous les trois à poil dans le désert où
les deux duels
c'est comme marcher le pêne je les
[ __ ] tous les deux on me dit de
choisir un des données jouer des airs
gerland quelqu'un alors lequel le caire
savoir qui va accepter et
un an m t'en fais pas pour lui allez
merci à toi genou les ordures les pièces
que alors maintenant on te demande est
ce qu'il sera tienne vous savez manier
l'art a déjà eu des rapports homosexuels
n'ont jamais mené avec le pen fn
quand j'étais petit on te demande au
choiseul quant à léa 12 ans 8 ans pour
les garçons comme tout le monde à
l'espace étoile avec des projets sans
jamais répondre répond je dors plonge ya
vraiment pas de quoi être fier mais
c'est vrai dans quelle époque donc
c'était quand même l'époque de patrick
sabatier de michel drucker de tous ces
gens là qui était extrêmement gentil
avec les invités dont lui a cassé trois
côtes quand même ce jour là et il ya eu
plein d'histoires comme ça il ya une
histoire aussi avec karen cheryl qui
poussait à l'époque à tf1 et on lui
avait avec un tesson de bouteille
j'avais ouvert la main bon donc là on
s'est fait virer c'était le début de ma
carrière
ça a commencé très fort la première
vraie interview du coup c'est le 22
septembre 85
ça s'appelait scoop à la une et c'était
henri salvador ton invité alors on vient
me chercher en voiture on t'emmène au
studio tu retrouves catherine barma
productrice historique et qu'est ce que
tu lui dis bah non c'est pas ça c'est
que moi déjà j'étais papou savoir quand
même une chose faut dire aux gens qui
sont là aux jeunes c'est que jamais
personne veut être interviewer dans la
vie c'est à dire c'est pas un vrai
métier
quand on est petit on va être pompier on
va être pilote d'avion on dit jamais je
vais être interviewer bon moi je me
retrouve interviewer ben si ça me
faisait marrer après descente de police
je commençais à trouver ça intéressant
puis l'idée de faire de la télé quand
même ça me faisait marrer évidemment
donc finalement il propose une émission
qui est une espèce de jeu s'appelle
scoop à la une que tu n'as jeu en fait
très traditionnel où les gens devaient
faire la une d'un magazine qui
s'appelait scoop avec des extraits des
journaux télévisés de la semaine en
finale un jeu du journaliste en fait bon
moi je fais des répétitions j'étais à
chier mais très très très très mauvais
j'avais le trac je voulais pas fait en
fin de vie j'avais envie de le faire
mais c'est pas capable de le faire
donc aux répétitions j'étais vraiment
très très mauvais tout le monde je
sentais bien que les gens n'étaient pas
emballés par mois et quand arrive le
jour du tournage de la première émission
donc ils viennent me chercher en voiture
effectivement tout le monde de bagnols
les gonzesses des assistantes et tout ça
c'est mans est là arrivé sur le plateau
j'ai eu un trac épouvantable qui m'a
d'ailleurs pas quitter pendant les 15
années suivantes
un trac épouvantable et j'ai dit à
catherine barma je peux pas rentrer elle
me dit mais il ya tout le monde qui est
là il ya les caméras il ya 200 personnes
dans le public il ya les invités qui
sont dans les loges
si je peux pas y aller je suis plus fort
que moi je peux mais qu'est ce que tu
veux que je leur dise je lui dis dis
leur que j'ai le cancer ce qui était
très mauvaise excuse parce que le cancer
ça se déclenche pas en une demi heure
donc j'y suis allé et c'était
épouvantable
si sur un truc comme ça derrière mais on
va regarder magnéto c'est horrible qui
va limiter d'abord pour commencer le mec
qui présente son émission de télévision
pour la première fois à bon et bien bon
soir mais si un musée mais dû à part de
méthane ces messieurs aujourd'hui c'est
etc je suis très content du temps oui la
caméra fait bien non oui alors je
moi je trouve qu'il le fait mieux que
moi voilà donc c'était la première
interview on a pris le bon dans une
prise et le jour dans l'autre c'est à
dire heureusement que c'est monté
derrière mais c'était vraiment ils m'ont
détester sur la production parce que il
y avait trois heures de montage pour ce
soit à peu près normale il se tracte je
les ai eus pendant les 15 années
suivantes
ça m'a jamais quitté ça m'a un peu
quitté quand gainsbourg est venu ce
gainsbourg est venu dans cette émission
et à l'époque on pouvait boire à la télé
on pouvait sur les plateaux on pouvait
boire on pouvait fumer ça je pense sympa
et gainsbourg vient on va la voir tout
de suite cette cette séquence de
gainsbourg c'est parti bien bien bonjour
alors serge commandait le petit lulu
oh le petit lui est mignon est déjà
célèbre est déjà connu il a pas eu de
mal à peine il est né il est déjà connu
c'est un handicap alors tu l'a appelée
lucien comme ton vrai prénom
oui je vais plus réussi à aller tu l'a
appelée lucien tu veux qu'ils soient
peintres ou écrivains
j'aimerais qu'ils fassent et vos seins
comme toi j'ai eu à quoi répond tu
voudrais qu'ils paient nous qui
l'écrivons qu'il fasse de la musique ou
qu'il fasse les 3g est archi architectes
maillot on va se marrer ce gamin
maintenant mais je n'aime pas ça après
les footeux obligera pas si vous êtes
expert comptable par exemple alors mail
à mon coup de pub avec tout ce que tu
t'en vois tu avais pas peur qu'il soit
un peu mongolo lulu non sifflé foyen
fait pas peur il est mûr couvrir deux
radars imagine tu as pas eu peur nous
laisser tout ça tu étais pas c'était pas
les yeux de port bou oui la bouche pipe
et de son père ou de sa mère
c'est fini mais tu vas encore faire
beaucoup d'enfants comme ça mais c'est
le dernier pas décollé donc là
effectivement les gens il ya eu un buzz
dans paris c'est pas comme maintenant
avec internet on fait comme du buzz les
gens ont dit à un mec à la télé le
dimanche après midi il faut savoir que
c'est une mission qui est passé à 3
heures de l'après midi sur tf1
il ya un mec qui est nul on voit bien il
est complètement poté n'y arrive pas il
dit des trucs quand même très bizarre
quoi et là c'est devenu voilà c'est
comme ça que ça a commencé j'ai fini la
saison en faisant ça et puis je me suis
rendu compte que quand je choisis cette
émission là et que je voulais quand je
sortais de l'émission et que je voulais
être heureux content j'allais aux bains
douches qu'était la boîte de l'époque
est donc un an après je vais faire
l'émission directement aux bains douches
ce qui était quand même beaucoup plus
simple que de passer par le par bercy
parle paix au pb et voilà c'est en fait
ça a vraiment commencé avec bain de
minuit qu'est l'émission j'ai fait aux
bains douches ou là c'était vraiment moi
quoi c'était là c'est pas moi mais aux
bains douches c'était moi avec mes amis
ma bande les gens de l'époque
voilà alors pour réussir une bonne
interview en tout cas la sauce ardisson
il ya un truc important c'est de trouver
la bonne longueur d'onde
oui je crois que la première chose à
faire c'est comme un canton cherche sur
une radio quoi quand on cherche le
tuning quoi c'est qu'il faut trouver la
longueur d'onde des gens c'est à dire
que si c'est très important alors ça
passe par des détails comme par exemple
moi je vois jamais les gens avant enfin
moins possible parce que si tu deviens
copain avec les gens que tu interview
après tu peux plus leur poser des
questions
dur donc c'est vrai que - bizarrement
mais je connais pas fréquenter grand
monde et je connais pas grand monde
quand j'ai commencé à faire du cinéma
tout le monde ma vie
je les connais tous j oui je connais
tous mais il déteste tous donc donc
c'est vrai qu'à la longueur d'onde il
faut trouver le bon
le regard avec les gens évidemment après
il ya le jargon c'est à dire que les
mots qu'on emploie avec un philosophe
sont pas les mêmes que ceux qu'on
emploie avec un rappeur ça va de soi
mais encore faut-il y faire attention
parce que les gens ils vous calcule si
vous employez les bons mots ou si vous
avez les bonnes références culturelles
en deux secondes disent ok je peux lui
parler je peux lui faire confiance à
très vite en déjà bon quand je passe le
leur dire bonjour au maquillage juste
trouver les mots qui vont les mettre en
confiance très important donc la
longueur d'onde le jargon
et puis ce qu'on sait des gens c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est comme les flics
si un flic des bars chez vous un matin
et vous dit hier soir à 10h00 dans un
petit japonais de la rue machin [ __ ]
le mec qui sait ça il s'est tout quoi
alors qu'en fait il sait peut-être que
ça donc avec les invités avec les gens
qu'on interview il faut savoir deux
trois détails qui tuent et qui font que
le mec se dit bon mais je vais pas lui
raconter de conneries parce
qu'apparemment il sait tous ses 10 ans
trois recettes mais il faut beaucoup
travailler en fait tout ça a l'air enfin
quand je dis magique contre on voit les
gens de la télé en je vais regarder mon
émission de samedi soir 19h
je vois ça je me dis peut-être que les
gens pensent que c'est facile en fait
c'est un faux naturel c'est pas du tout
naturel c'est c'est du théâtre la télé
il faut comprendre ça je crois que quand
les vrais journalistes comme florent
exempt mais quand on est animateur de
talk show il faut savoir que c'est que
c'est la comédienne alors il ya un
exemple
que j'ai retenue elle s'appelle milla
jovovich c'était le 23 mars 2002
regardez ce que ça donne quand ils
regardent ils ont dit que de temps en
temps il faut connaître tout même les
petits détails dont vous vivez à londres
vous êtes un petit peu rebelle comme ça
vous faites de la musique vous êtes
obligé de rentrer en amérique vous
rentrez en amérique de toute urgence
parce que votre père a été arrêté pour
fraude à l'assurance et à celle de ma
famille c'est vrai effectivement mon
père a passé huit ans de prison
voilà alors oui j'ai perdu mon père
pendant huit ans
[Musique]
chercheur
à l'inversé
[Musique]
besson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc voilà ça c'est les dangers trop
travailler parce que cette fille mila
jovovich contre qui je n'ai évidemment
rien chaque fois qu'elle venait en
france tout le monde lui dit rien vous
êtes formidable j'ai été marié qu'une
besson vous avez joué de l'ange ndar est
en général le travail des journalistes
qui l'interviewaient s'arrêter là donc
évidemment tout se passait bien
sauf que moi je suis renseigné sur l
savoir ce qu'elle faisait en amérique
avant de venir ce que faisait son père
ce que faisait sa mère ce que c'est son
frère et donc je les trouvais que son
père avait été en prison donc j'ai pas
apparemment ça ne choque beaucoup qu'on
en parle en même temps il avait purgé sa
peine mais comme elle avait pris un
petit peu des substances je pense elle
s'est énervée voilà mais ça partait d'un
j'ai pas d'un bon sentiment mais ça
partait d'un réel professionnels et
trouver la bonne longueur d'onde donc
vous avez compris que c'était important
l'un des secrets aussi de l'interview à
la ardisson que j'ai déjà disséqué c'est
l'absence de tabou aucune censure dont à
peu près tous les domaines
quelle que soit la personne en face de
vous et temps en temps il faut pas céder
à la pression 18 mars 2000 sur soi
edouard balladur et en préparant les
missions entre pasqua 5,6 coup de fil à
la suite oui mais quand on est un canton
va recevoir des gens vous avez toujours
l'entourage qui vous appelle quand il ya
un problème dans les huit jours
précédents et voilà là en l'occurrence
c'était balladur il faut pas lui dire
qu'il est turc
pourquoi je dois pas lui dire qu'il est
dur il faut pas lui dire qu'il est sûrs
tu dis pas qu'ils durent donc évidemment
qu'on ballade you est arrivé à une chose
que j'ai fait j tible ça fait huit jours
comme dit vous dire que vous ne pas vous
dire que vous êtes turgis ses lectures
qui a déjà eu à des turcs ont pillé turc
super et franchement il voulait pas en
parler
bon le lendemain matin coup de téléphone
de balladur dont j'étais au montage coup
de téléphone de balla diop et je ne suis
pas sûr si vous voulez venir à mon
bureau je vais vous prouver que je ne
suis pas turgis ma tournée on s'en fout
le mec est né à izmir
c'est à dire smyrne aujourd'hui c'est
izmir qu est une ville en fête sur la
côte anatolienne
où il y avait beaucoup de beaucoup de
nos populations différentes
j'écoutais non non je vais pas venir à
votre bureau moi je vous crois bon vous
êtes passionnant il faut le couper dans
l'émission j'ai un hommage coupe jamais
donc pas la peine de me demander
j'appelle comme la patronne de france 2
à l'époque était michèle cotta jeté une
journaliste j qu'est ce que t'en pense à
me du fait chier c'est bizarre ce qu'il
soit un millier coup je le vois ce soir
chez chez mariage de je sais plus qui je
vais lui en parler
enfin toujours est il que l'émission est
passé telle qu'elle est bien des années
après en fait balladur je vois pas plus
de honte à ça d'ailleurs il est armé
bien et je comprends quand on lui dit si
je puis dire qu'ils étaient turcs
je comprends que ça l'embêtait beaucoup
mais ils auraient pu me le dire je veux
bien que tu ais je m'appelle balladur et
en arménien ma famille est arrivée à
marseille au moment du génocide dans les
années 20 ma famille s'est installée à
marseille et au lieu de s'appeler
balladur orient s'appelait balladur il
ya quand même rien d'extraordinaire et
donc ça ça a été une des fois où j'ai
vraiment une grosse pression
contrairement à ce qu'on raconte on n'a
pas beaucoup de pression parce que les
gens en fait ils savent ce qu'ils
acceptent les pressions et ceux qui les
acceptent pas moi ils savent que de
toute façon j accepte pas les pressions
donc je n'aime ou pas beaucoup là c'est
lui qui m'a mis la pression mais la
direction de france 2 m'a m'a soutenu et
s'est passé comme ça et regarder
l'extrait
alors je me posais une question vous
avez m'en vouloir mais joli j'y suis
obligé de vous la poser parce que quand
on a j'ai eu des conversations
téléphoniques avec votre entourage pour
réparer cette émission ils m'ont dit
faut pas lui parler de ça et moi non
mais c'est pas quelque chose de
scandaleux et je le dis tout de suite je
me permettrai pas moi je pense qu'on m'a
dit il faut pas parler à edouard
balladur de ses origines turques
parce que ça va l'énerver oui c'est
alors je vois pas non excusez moi je
continue puis je vous cède la parole moi
je vois pas ce qu'il ya d'abord
évidemment de péjoratif à être d'origine
turque
surtout que votre famille on peut en
parler d'eux depuis très longtemps lié à
la france puisque vous étiez d une
famille de citoyens ottomans et protégé
français protégés de deux longues de
longue date
alors moi je comprends pas parce que des
fois on vous reproche d'être hautain
d'être distant et en fait vous êtes
immigrés oui si on se présente à matam
il est effectivement devenue française
il ya quelques générations qu'il faut là
quoi c'est tout c'est comme si on ne
peut pas lui en parler de façon générale
je parle très peu de moi
bon j'ai pris un risque en venant chez
vous et vous l'aurez noté par 9 voix on
va voir on va voir les invités de vos
émissions vous demande parfois d'avoir
les questions à l'avance ne demande pas
en revanche sur certaines interviews
qu'ils sont ce que japan en parlera
après les interviews formaté ces acquis
sont en fait des petits sketchs quand
j'ai un comique qui doit venir dans
l'émission je suis tout un écrivain par
exemple quelqu'un qui sait écrire je
vais lui donner avant mais c'est pas des
interviews qui concerne leur vie
cd je donc ça je le fais mais sinon
jamais quand tu demandes les est
question ils ont pas ou alors je leur
donne des souvent il faut aller boire un
verre enfin souvent de temps en temps
fait de boire un verre avec la personne
que qui dit moi je veux bien viens chez
ardisson à condition que je le rencontre
avant donc on y va on raconte n'importe
quoi et ils sont très contents
puis quand il arrive sur le plateau on
fait ce qu'on veut une fois il ya
françois hollande qui avient à quand il
était candidat il a dit moi je vais je
bien venu 1 6-10 ans mais je veux
déjeuner avec lui d'abord donc j'ai
déjeuné avec françois hollande je veux
dire un truc horrible je me souviens de
rien non mais de rien de rien du tout je
me souviens que j'ai beaucoup parlé j'ai
sans doute dit des conneries parce qu'il
n'est pas venu
tabou sur le a est peut-être encore une
question là bas là bas merci bonsoir
bonsoir à bouffe
j'ai deux petites questions une sur le
trac dont vous avez parlé avant je
voulais savoir si pendant ces quinze
années où vous avez entre guillemets
souffert de ce tract vous avez songé à
tout arrêter et la deuxième c'est
comment est-ce que vous gérez et vous
avez géré ce trac pendant ces années il
y a des petits des recettes mais je
voulais c'est vrai que n'importe qui
aurait arrêté parce que la boule au
ventre que j'avais en allant faire
l'émission c'était insupportable
franchement insupportable je montre
comment j'ai fait alors un moment on m'a
dit il faut prendre des bêtabloquants
donc j'ai pris des bêtabloquants mais ça
me rendait endormi pour le moins je
manqué de vivacité
j'étais pas très en forme avec ses bêta
bloquants après un jour il ya jacques
martin qui vient dans mon émission et
qui me dit tu y ailles j'ai un truc pour
toi tu vas manger du sel le sel absorber
la transpiration là ça te faire un bien
fou et j'ai pris comme chez un copain
m'a cassé jusqu'au boutiste j'ai pris
une demi boîte de sel serré beauce
évidemment je n'ai pas transpiré j'ai
pas eu le trac mais tellement mal au
bide que j'avais pas le trac pierre
chaise j'ai pas du tout transpire et
simplement rentrant chez moi j'ai eu des
coliques néphrétiques évidemment
épouvantable sa seule fois de ma vie où
ça m'était arrivé je souhaite ça à
personne
tous ces cristaux de sel en traversant
les reins un parrain me faisais
affreusement souffrir et on a été obligé
de me faire une piqûre de valium manger
pour répondre sérieusement votre
question j'ai jamais rien trouvé
jusqu'au jour où j'ai fait une émission
quotidienne sur paris première qui
s'appelait rive droite rive gauche et là
je me suis dit j'en ai eu marre d'avoir
le trac
celle là je me suis dit si tu fais une
quotidienne et elle traque tous les
jours faut pas la faire mon gars là
vraiment pas là je me suis dit il faut
pas y aller voilà j'ai commencé à
surmonter
je crois qu'en fait on se débarrasse de
cette addiction
quand on en a marre moi dans les années
70 j'avais pris de l'héroïne pendant
trois quatre ans
je me suis arrêté d'en prendre le jour
j'en ai eu marre d'en prendre parce que
la vie que ça me faisait mener ne me
plaisait pas et ça c'est une bonne façon
de se guérir c'est quand on en a marre
j'ai aimé eu marre d'avoir le trac et
gemma ceci étant voilà quand même quoi
je veux dire il faut avoir un petit trac
il faut toujours avoir une petite
appréhension parce que si si on y va en
pensant que c'est simple c'est pas vrai
c'est pas simple moi j'ai quand même
tous les samedis soir un million et demi
de gens qui me regardent ces gens là je
dois pas les décevoir je sais le deal
donc ça fout la pression
quelqu'un qui vous dirai ça me fout pas
la pression c'est pas vrai alors on
parlait du des tabous sur la sur la
forme sur le fond il ya une émission qui
s'appelait hardy matt 92 sur france 2 et
alors là le concept était génial je sais
pas s'il pourra marcher d'ailleurs
encore aujourd'hui tu as dû le déposer
si j'avais su le faire il aurait marché
c'est à dire qu'à l'epoque chaque fois
qu'on arrêtait une émission jean zay une
autre j'en faisais comme ça trois par an
mais que mal le csa m'avait avec intel
cessa de l'époque m'avait arrêtée double
jeu donc j'ai dit c'est pas grave on
fait une route mans est en effet une
émission qui s'appelait hardy matt le
concept c'était on est en direct
on doit faire de l'audience il y avait
un chien ça vous êtes trop jeunes posent
en souvenir et je disais si vous ne
regardez si l'audience baisse je tue le
chien
donc les gens les gens chez eux cela peu
obligé de regarder ces sinon le chien
mourir
et le problème c'est que j'étais nul
c'est à dire que j'étais vraiment pas
vraiment pas bon pour faire ça et je
faisais pas en direct ce qui était
complètement de con je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour répondre à ta
question c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
serait bien ce serait de le faire c'est
un peu ce que fait hanouna pascal moulin
pendant son émission
il a un portable il à son audience en
direct donc hissé pendant la pub il
regarde son audience et en revenant de
la pub il fait un truc pour la continuer
à la faire monter
donc nous on aurait pu nous hisser au 2e
degré mais bon on aurait plus on
pourrait le faire aujourd'hui avec ces
systèmes d'audience en direct en dix ans
le 10 ans baisse d'audience monde vont
en effet cette émission qui s'appelait
hardy matt et c'est l'émission la plus
n'importe quoi que j'ai fait de ma vie
et j'ai trouvé un régale d'avancé
vous allez voir donc c'est derrida le
philosophe français qui mourir quoi en
2004 autre chose comme ça invité de
l'émission hardy matt regardez ce que ça
donne donc du coup faut faire de
l'audience à ça le concept comment vous
pensez aujourd'hui le rapport entre
philosophie littérature et est ce que
finalement les par contre ont été les
vôtres et dans la philosophie et dans la
littérature ne vous conduisent pas à
penser que l'écriture littéraire
finalement résout des problèmes que la
philosophie pose sans être capable de
les résoudre
j'hésite à répondre à cette question là
parce que si je répondais je dirais
voilà ses jalons ont quelque chose en
commun et ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
qu'ils ont en commun
bon vous avez compris dans l'idée alors
j'étais assis derrière un bureau est à
côté de moi il y avait le professeur
rollin joué par françois rollin est un
type exceptionnel et qui me disait
thierry mais faut faire de l'audience
non moi je dis bah c'est bien pour faire
du pardo si le service public en même
temps donc on n'avait pas si cette
interview de jacques derrida en internat
interposant des photos pornos et à la
sortie nous disaient ouais c'est bien à
prendre avait diffusé un film porno mais
comme si le service public on avait
diffusé à l'envers la sortie du magnéto
tout le monde était comme ça c'était on
se foutait de la gueule de l'audience
que c'était vachement bien l'idée était
bien mais moi j'étais pas assez bon pour
pour faire ça comme il faut alors il ya
une autre recette c'est la mise en scène
ça c'est important aussi dans
l'interview à lardy sont ils à canal
la télé c'est du spectacle en fait c'est
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure que 50%
de fond 50% de fun 50% une forme 50% de
fond c'est à dire qu'en fait le le très
difficile pour les journalistes les
vrais journalistes d'imaginer que la
télévision c'est avant tout de l'image
dire que si vous regardez le journal
télévisé de 20 heures
quelle que soit la nouvelle qu'on vous
annonce la première chose que vous
regardez c'est la gueule du maigre et
puis la fatigue et sa cravate est pas
bien etc
c'est très payant à la télévision dans
les églises catholiques et des statuts
mais dans les temples protestants n'y a
pas de statut la représentation de
l'humain est très païenne donc c'est
vrai qu'à la télé il faut admettre ça
c'est à dire qu'en fait tout est faussé
par sa sur tout ce que vous dites tout
ce que vous faites est faussé par
l'apparence les gens il commence par
regarder comment vous êtes donc quand on
fait de la télé faut en tenir compte
pour moi c'est vrai que dans la pub
j'avais appris la forme dire que quand
tu arrives à la télé par exemple il y
avait des curés comme les supermarchés
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un grill se
plaint grillé vaincre île de lumière et
les gens étaient tous éclairés à giorno
quoi comme dans un supermarché et on a
été les premiers à mettre des
contre-jours derrière des contres qui
modèlent les cheveux des succès des
détails mais c'est des choses qu'on
améliorer la qualité de l'image à la
télévision et donc effectivement où il
faut il faut se soucier de la forme et
ça passe aussi par des heures là en
l'occurence n'était pas le cas mais ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure sur les sur
les concepts s'est inspiré des shows
américains en fait un
letterman oui moi ce que je sais ce que
je fais aujourd'hui c'est un ce que vous
états unis on appelle un light show
c'est à dire effectivement on est face à
un invité on lui pose des questions
tout le monde en parle et est un genre
de talk show très différent parce qu'il
y avait à la fin de la soirée il y avait
10 personnes autour de la table
là on est plus près des shows américains
de gélineau de david letterman etc
oui c'est one to one bon nous il ya
quelques autres personnes en fin
d'interview quand même les uns après les
autres et puis à le rôle du sniper alors
le sniper moi j'ai commencé avec baffie
donc qui est venu me voir chez moi un
jour j'avais besoin d'un auteur pour
écrire des pour écrire des bons soirs il
vient me voir chez moi et il me montre
une ue je veux bien de faire des trucs
mais il me montre une cassette il était
sur les champs elysées il interviewait
des gens qui avaient des blousons en
skaï et leur disais mais c'est terrible
quand même vous portez du sky vous
pensez à la maman sky quand quand on tue
ses enfants et tous et les gens disaient
ouais c'est vrai quoi donc j'ai vu ça et
j'ai dit mais ce mec est juste géniale
et donc on a commencé à travailler
ensemble à la fois et viser des sujets
par exemple il avait un truc était très
rigolo c'est qu'il avait demandé aux
gens ce qu'ils pensaient de présenter la
vie jean edern hallier et a invité dans
l'émission
peu importe qui ils allaient voir les
gens en posant qu'est ce que vous pensez
du commandant cousteau alors les gens
disaient commandant cousteau ça tu te
remets mc2 le passé pas donc le mec vous
voyez tous les compliments
il est très marrant moi il m'a toujours
beaucoup fait rire long et donc je les
prie pour sniper mais moi j'ai pris
laurent pour faire des vannes c'est à
dire que moi j'avais pas besoin sur le
fond de l'interview je savais le faire
ce que je savais pas faire c'était les
vannes et laurent effectivement une
fulgurance c'est un des rares moments
comme ça il est capable de sortir la
vanne dans la première demie seconde
il scanne pour voir s'il a pas une vanne
en stock et dans la deuxième demi
seconde il en trouve une fois c'est
juste un mec éblouissant aujourd'hui
c'est différent aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas vraiment de sniper les gens
par exemple comme l'émission de ruquier
par exemple aymeric caron
c'est pas des snipers c'est des gens qui
sont là pour poser des questions de
l'animateur n'osent pas poser
c'est pas pareil un sniper c'est
quelqu'un qui doit à un moment trouver
la bonne vanne
je me souviens d'une fois il y avait
jean rochefort alors j'ai dit laurent tu
connais jean rochefort jean rochefort
l'autre commence à faire la gueule quand
même parce qu'il est quand même assez
imbu de lui-même
jean rochefort l'on mène on écoute je
connais pas genre je te dis bon je
connais pas et au bout d'un moment
peut-être quatre minutes plus tard cinq
minutes plus tard il fait beau ce fort
rochefort ce mec était géniale hors des
comme lui il y en a qu'un après j'en ai
essayé d'autres quand il était malade on
prenait kad et olivier on appris on en a
pris d'autres mais il n'ya que laurent
est aujourd'hui il n'a pas été remplacé
je pense je vois pas la télé joue et je
vois des gens qui font chier les inviter
à la place de l'animateur mais je vois
pas de mec fait des vannes drôle et moi
quand je suis arrivé à canal la
direction de canal m'a dit écoute on
t'adore et tous étaient gentils que je
ne me faire virer de france 2010 coûte
vraiment on veut s'engager tout ça mais
on veut pas de laurent baffie je dis
pourquoi on veut pas de laurent baffie
parce que si tu veux pas revenir chez
canal faire la même chose que tu as fait
sur france 2 pendant dix ans n'a pas
faire la même chose
jv qui va faire les vannes et ils m'ont
dit toi je suis incapable de faire des
lames et ils m'ont dit tu as des bons
auteurs oui j'ai des bons auteurs donc
j'ai appris ce boulot qui je ne
connaissais pas et pourtant j'avais déjà
pratiquement 60 piges
j'ai appris ce métier de comédien c'est
à dire de vendre des vannes qu'on n'a
pas écrite pas toujours écrite disons et
c'était un long apprentissage pour
arriver à vendre des vannes à faire des
vannes comme si on les improvisé c'est
ce que font très bien mais les les
les gens qui animent les talk shows aux
états unis je racontais l'autre jour à
florent qu'aux états unis
ils répètent les interviews l'après midi
ça aussi c'est important que pour ceux
qui se veulent travailler dans ces
boulots de l'audiovisuel se sache
c'est à dire que l'après midi à l'invité
qui vient l'animateur il répète
l'interview l'animateur à ses auteurs
l'invité à des auteurs qui lui sont
dédiés il répète l'interview il améliore
ils trouvent des vab et le soir ils
jouent l'interview devant les caméras et
ça je crois que pour des français parce
que nous on a une idée du journaliste
c'est des choses je dis pas qu'il faut
faire pareil
le dic en tous les cas il faut savoir
que ça existe alors faire des vannes ça
veut dire ça on après un extrait salut
les terriens c'était nagui alors nadi en
fait c'est ici ce soir pour célébrer
votre victoire au grand jeu de france 2
tout le monde veut prendre ma place un
jeu dans lequel des candidats comme
sophia aram bruno guillon laurent
ruquier se sont pourtant essayé mais
c'est vous qui avez gagné vous tenez le
coup nagui vous animez deux jeux par
jour sur france 2 tout le monde veut
prendre sa place
du lundi au dimanche à 12 heures et
n'oubliez pas les paroles du lundi au
vendredi à 18h50 alors compte tenu du
vieillissement téléspectateurs de france
le jeu s'appellera bientôt
n'oubliez pas votre prénom
ça cartonne et sahraoui
alors on parle du retour de que le
meilleur gagne ouais que vous animiez en
1991 ça fait 23 ans s'est plaint des
michel marty ça a marché
nom de zeus nagui quand on travaille
autant on gagne de l'argent
c'est vrai qu'à saint tropez vos bateaux
vous les appelez france 2 et france 4
ça serait une bonne idée le jour j'aurai
des bateaux peut-être bah oui et la
maison blanche perdait la redevance pas
de bateau et puis à pons inter ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que magee à la maison
quand il était petit ses parents
écoutent et france inter france inter
nagui s'est un petit peu là la bande
originale de votre enfance n'avait radio
france et la première le premier contrat
de travail que j'ai ça compte quand même
dans une vie bien sûr c'était un
dimanche d'octobre 82 et où je rentrais
radio voilà et la musique aussi un oui
ça c'est des moments c'est à dire en
fait ça j'ai toujours la pub en fait je
m'en rends compte ce que avec la lumière
et cette année j'ai fait un nouveau truc
ça avant j'avais les samplers en tout le
monde en parle j'avais une trentaine de
sampler que je balançais en fonction la
g1 de nouveaux trucs s'appelle son et
lumière dire que quand j'appuie sur un
bouton ça envoie une musique et ça
change la lumière ça devient très très
sophistiqué on arrive à ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les interviews à la ardisson
parce qu'on dit ça en tout cas dans le
métier nous on dit ça ce que ce que tu
appelles une interview formaté l'
avantage de ces interio formaté si vous
allez voir qu'on ça permet en tout cas
moi je vois bien en tant que journaliste
ça permet d'aller plus loin de poser des
questions qu'on ne devrait pas poser
dans une interview classique quoi on
peut être voir un extrait
michel rocard interview qui s'appelle
alerte rose 31 mars 2001 est ce que
préfère être caressé par quelqu'un qui
vous dégoûte ou battu par quelqu'un qui
vous aime a battu par quelqu'un qui mène
à attention vous seriez un peu non je
crois qu'on se renseigne ici vous savez
comment c'est est-ce que vous
préféreriez que votre femme vous quitte
pour un homme pour une autre femme à
partir dans le bon équilibre à el oued
et manquera c'est ça la gauche
peut-être d'ailleurs peut-être qu'elle
pâques c'est ce que embrasser s'est
trompé non ah bon puisque c'est que
cette philosophie que vous travaillez là
je sais pas je vous demande mal joué
mais ça dépend du contexte et j'espère
bien que non ouais et sucer c'est
tromper et pardon sucer c'est tromper
non plus non plus ça me poursuit depuis
je pense que jacques chancel n'a jamais
dit et dieu dans tout ça
et chaque fois qu'il a fait une
interview - et dieu dans tout ça moi
c'est pareil ça sur le moment d'ailleurs
ça a été complètement s'est passé
complètement inaperçu au tournage au
montage et la diffusion
ces quinze jours après que un
journaliste du monde que je respecte
énormément qui s'appelle daniel
schneidermann a écrit dans son journal
que c'était un scandale qu'on n'ose
poser des question pareille à un ancien
premier ministre
ce qu'il faut savoir en fait c'est
qu'avant ça j'avais fait 23 minutes
d'interview de rocard en lui parlant de
la csg tout il m'avait dit c'est la
première fois qu'on me parle de la csg
comme ça à la télé tout est très content
fait est là aussi
dans les interviews formats tels
avantages bon moi quand je suis arrivé à
la télé disons il y avait des interviews
les gens bonjour comment ça va vous
faites un film fait un discours est tout
j'ai en fait c'étaient des conversations
plus que des interviews après il y avait
un truc qui existe et c'était le ce
qu'on appelle le questionnaire de proust
qui n'a pas du tout a été inventé par
proust mais on appelle aux questions de
proue ce qui est en fait un jeu de
société de la fin du 19e siècle dans les
salons et puis ça s'arrêtait là non moi
ce que j'ai inventé oui c'est une
cinquantaine de formats d'interviews
l'interview première fois l'interview
alerte aux roses
l'interview fans à 50 il pendant des
années j'ai fait ça et ça marchait bien
et c'était un peu une marque de fabrique
ça permet aussi ce que disait flanc
c'est à dire quand un invité est en
promotion qu'il a un film à vendre un
disque à vendre un livre à vendre
il a un discours promotionnel
préprogrammés et ce discours vous pouvez
pas souvent yann barthès fait ça très
bien vous dit à peu près la même chose
en tout cas dans toutes les émissions
il répète la même chose ils font leur
promotion l' avantage des interviews
formaté c'est que d'un seul coup on les
amène sur des terrains où ils sont
complètement surpris et ils sont eux
mêmes parce que là c'est pas préparés
ils ont en général vendu leur lire ils
sont tranquilles et là on les amène là
dessus donc j'ai fait ça pendant des
années il y avait des interviews il y
avait les interviews nul
il y avait failli et plein d'idées comme
ça et puis un jour je me suis rendu
compte que finalement c'était toujours
les dit même que j'utilisais et que
c'était lassant pour les gens parce que
l'interview alerte au rouge une
interview première fois il la voyait
pratiquement deux fois par mois
et là j'ai pris des auteurs avec qui je
travaille toujours d'ailleurs
à commencer par kader aoun qui a été le
le collaborateur de jamel debbouze
pendant des années qui maintenant
produit norman djamel pis tout comme
stéphane ribeiro et c est là je leur ai
demandé d'écrire des interviews sur
mesure en fonction des invités sur que
par exemple si françoise hardy venez
andine interview chpa thermolactyl de
damart c'est à dire ce que voilà est-ce
que comme tous les garçons et les filles
de votre âge vous avez les jambes un peu
gonflé le soir donc silence et lui fait
vraiment plaisir
voilà donc les interviews était en
fonction par exemple quand il ya anne
hidalgo qui est venu j'ai fait une
interview vamos a la playa qu'on nous
ressasse à redonner de l'intérêt à ses
interviews formaté et encore une fois
ça permet de créer avec les invités des
petits moments de fun
ils jouent le jeu en général plutôt bien
et ça permet de sortir de ce qu'on
entend dans les autres tokyo et puis ça
permet aussi de faire des interviews
t'as même pas besoin de poser des
questions
roland dumas dans salut les terriens
regardez alors aujourd'hui ma est ce que
comme françois mitterrand vous croyez
aux forces de l'esprit beaucoup ça tombe
bien parce qu'on va faire une interview
mitterrand spirit
[Musique]
je t'écoute françois tiens tu m'as
qu'est ce que vous faites là mon vieux
est-ce que vous baisez toujours autant
[Rires]
pourquoi pas tu m'as ya quoi comme bon
bouquin sorti sur moi récemment
est-ce qu'ils le savent pour marc karine
ma deuxième fille cachée et daniel elle
va bien elle est mort il paraît qu'elle
ait eu une aventure alors que le sous
commandant marcos est ce que c'est vrai
on a dit que l'état amoureux
enfin alors que tu avais la wii voilà
bon et ségolène royal a elle est
toujours là et oui les gens pensent
toujours que c'est méfie aussi un
message sais pas si c'est ta fille et
rocard rocard wissant va doucement
et vous allez-vous elle ne s'en va pas
aller toujours mignonne non mais c'est
vrai que ont peu apprécié ces comme des
sketches quoi j'avais une interview sa
pleine interview cercueil et donc
l'invité était dans son cercueil et ont
interviewé comme s'il était mort déjà
donc c'est vrai que c'est après ça peut
mettre mal à l'aise il y avait l'auto
interview où léa c'était très compliqué
l'auto interview parce qu'il faut
d'abord tourné vous mettez de palombes
des lunettes noires à l'invité ils
tournent toutes les questions et à prix
tournent toutes les réponses et après on
monte voilà ça c'était le principe de
l'auto interview bon c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu plein d'expérience comme ça de y
avait une interview si feu
j'étais dieu donc déjà cueilli et
l'inviter au paradis et on peut tout
faire et c'est vrai que en fait ça c'est
un truc qui m'a beaucoup intéressé c'est
de jouer sur l'interview puisque
l'interview c'est le rapport c'est le
premier rapport avec les gens en
interview et alors il ya deux autres
exercices parce qu'on a vu du plateau
paris dernière caméra subjective paris
dernière j'étais je m'étais fait virer
de france 2 déjà en 93 et j'étais à la
rue et je suis allé voir paris première
en leur disant je devais faire une
émission pour vous ils m'ont dit on n'a
pas d'argent
j'ai fait l'émission la moins chère du
monde c'est à dire qu'on avait une
caméra peut pas être moins cher et c'est
une caméra subjective donc et si une
dérive l'actu enfin vous connaissez
démission parce qu'après avait été
reprise par frédéric taddéï et par
d'autres gens par la suite c'était une
émission vraiment j'ai adoré cette
émission en fait parce que on partait le
soir dans paris il ya un certain nombre
de rendez-vous qui a été fixé
évidemment quand on arrivait chez les
gens ils avaient déjà le micro et la
lumière été faites y avait une équipe
qui passait d'abord donc nous partout on
arrivait l'équipe était passé une demi
heure avant pour préparer donc c'est
bien ça le mec ouvrait la porte que ça
semblait vrai
et après quand on se traîner dans la rue
ont continué à brancher des gens à les
interviews et tout et c'est vrai que
c'est une
c'est une expérience en même temps très
intéressant que j'ai quand même traîner
dans les nuits de paris pour faire ça
oui vous voyez des bouteilles d'eau
voilà alors c'est à chaque système
relativement simples qu'on a pris parce
que toutes les poupées sont gonflés way
ou moins pendant une nuit avant d'être
mis dans le commerce doit être certain
qu'ils aient pas du bit et settat donc
on a un souci de la qualité alors là
elles sont sur l'envers donc il faut pas
regarder l'aspect de finition puisque là
elles sont sur l'envers et la peau sera
retourné pour donner cette peau de latex
très brillant très lisse et très
agréable au toucher elles sont
retournées à l'envers c'est pour ça que
voilà à présent des sacres voilà donc
fabrice exemple abl donc on a traîné on
était les premiers à filmer dans des
boîtes de deux fois des boîtes de tous
quoi des eaux cléopâtre je me souviens
on allait voir des libertins et les mecs
nous répond avec make baiser quand ils
n'ont répondu aux interviews
mais il ya eu des moments très
difficiles il ya eu des gens parce qu'à
force d'aller la nuit chercher ce qui se
passe on était tombé sur un mec qui sont
trip c'était de se faire habiller un
bébé et de se faire talk et il venait de
lyon une fois par semaine se faire talk
et se faire habiller un bébé il est
vraiment des trucs qui mettait mal à
l'aise quoi après c'est à dei qui s'en
est occupé
et puis alors il ya un autre concept
d'interviews parce qu'on en a balayé pas
mal c'est l'interview à la maison ça ça
jamais été
ces 93 faubourg saint-honoré l'idée de
faire un recueil d'idées de faire une
émission au cours d'un dîner jeudi pas
pour moi qui l'inventé j'imagine qu'à
des gens qui aient pensé avant je crois
que le vrai truc qui a fait le succès de
cette émission c'est que c'était
vraiment chez moi c'est à dire que les
gens quand ils arrivent ici mais c'est
vraiment chez toi ou ici chez moi c'est
un peu dur à vivre parce que le jour du
tournage le lundi il arrivait chez moi
le matin il est l'écart dans la rue il y
avait des files dans la cour ils
mettaient des métiers des lumières
partout face et pas très d'ailleurs
entre deux émissions ils essaient les
lumières au plafond mais c'était trop
long de les enlever et donc les gens
venez chez moi et là c'est un boulot
complètement différent c'est très
intéressant aussi pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'interview parce que au
lieu d'avoir par exemple moi quand
j'arrive dans salut les terriens le
syndic je fais une interview je sais
tout du mec joue tous à voir parce que
quand on sait tout peut pas vous
raconter de conneries
donc je suis en sait plus que lui sur
lui et le challenge c'est ça c'est que
le mec peut tout lui demander parce que
dès qu'il ya un truc je sais exactement
là c'est un exercice radicalement
différent cdg invité les gens chez moi
donc il fallait donner l'impression que
c'était chez moi donc le mec arrivé j'ai
qu'est ce tu fais en ce moment tu sais
pas je viens de sortir un film
ah non voilà donc c'était tout l'inversé
de complètement l'exercice inverse
c'était deux de considérer les gens qui
venaient comme des potes qui viennent
chez vous pour bouffer pour boire un
coup alors on s'asseyait on avait des
bons cuisiniers qui faisait la cuisine
moi j'ai jamais dîné chez moi je déteste
ça j'ai testé odeurs de cuisine mais là
il est très bon cuisinier qui venait et
après on bouffe et on buvait des coûts
et ça devenait comme un vrai dîner quoi
les gens étaient les jambes ne m'en
étais torché comme dans un vrai dîner
raconter n'importe quoi il oublier les
caméras et voilà et donc s'adonner des
moments il parlait tout seul
souvent d'ailleurs dû coûter un peu
besoin de les relancer quoi alors moi
j'étais au fond de matha moi je parlais
pas beaucoup en fait dans cette émission
parce que lister sens lundi n'est donc
le maître de l'hôte 10 on n'a pas trop
se mettre en valeur non plus donc j'ai
laissé parler et puis dans l'oreillette
parce qu'il avait emballé le car le mec
mais lee wallace sa baisse un peu mon co
producteur stéphane simon il me disait
balassa baisse un peu à l'âge de 10 ans
je suis d'accord je dis c'est un truc
qui remettait du bois dans la cheminée
il recommençait à s'engueuler c'était
reparti pour ce qui est du jamais vu
d'habitude montré un extrait ouais
un jour il ya un mec qui m'appellent
pour les terminer monsieur marc o dia
bonjour est ce que vous feriez le
téléthon je suis désolé je suis déçu
d'éviter que la sclérose en plaques
je pensais qu'ils allaient devoir y
venir rsa remplit et le mec il a dix ans
voir il m'a jamais rappelée d'être dû
dire en réunion bon farrugia il a été et
est grand c'est le dur dont tout le
monde en parle quand je dis comment ça
va il m'a dit tu sais ton corps à la
santé mais ça je trouve que c'est une
une vanne des filles à la demande c'est
la première dame que je fais c'est quoi
ces les uns c'est après après après 12
ans de lui chaque fois chez les van
dessus fait il y avait au bout d'un
moment où il y avait une vraie ambiance
encore une fois je déteste les dîners
moi mon grand plaisir c'est d'aller
dîner tout seul avec ma femme mes mails
ah bon je le faisais c'est un travail je
le faisais proprement en donnant
l'impression que j'adorais dîner on va
parler de deux autres choses avant le
vent la faille avant tout les questions
déjà ce que parce que certains veulent
poser des questions salut la caméra je
m'appelle romain salut thierry c'est une
question un peu frontale
qu'est ce qui t'est déjà fait fermer ta
gueule juger vraiment c'est pas sur un
plateau de télévision personnes une fois
je lui manquait me faire casser la
gueule par joey starr mais c'était pas
sur un plateau de télé qui tu connais
quelqu'un qui m'a fait fermer ma gueule
non je crois pas jusqu'ici non moi je je
j'ai eu des mauvais moments
j'ai eu des moments de désagréable avec
des gens qui s'énervent avec des gens
qui par exemple il ya un mec je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez jimmy somerville
un jour il vient et ses lunettes noires
pour nuits blanches j'avais mes fiches
qui était là et il y à l'envers
puisqu'il était assis là on était comme
ça il y à l'envers qu'est ce que ça te
fait quand on s'appelle tranche de
patates
évidemment le mec s'est émerveillé les
parties a eu des départs il n'y a pas
des gens qui m'ont fait fermer ma gueule
mais j'ai eu pas mal de départs
sinéad o'connor qui voulait plus qu'on
lui parle du fait qu'elle avait déchiré
la photo du pape qui est parti en
courant dans la rue alors quand les gens
s'en vont comme nous on a une émission à
faire donc là on le supplie de revenir
c'est horrible c'est là on est vraiment
nul
question subsidiaire
oui quels amis à toi a refusé de faire
l'émission tous mes amis non mais il
faut pas avoir d'amis voilà c'est un
truc que c'est valable pour tout repos
en tous les cas pour tous les
journalistes pas que pour moi je crois
que moi par exemple un mec avec qui je
suis devenu ami au bout d'un moment
c'est yvan attal et ça me fait chier
quand je le reçois parce que c'est un
copain ça un ami donc il vient sur le
plateau je suis obligée de lui dire que
ce que parler de sa femme tout ça enfin
c'est pas agréable
il vaut mieux pas les connaître comme ça
on peut moi je dit souvent ça je dis moi
quand je fais des interviews je suis
comme un dentiste en fait je suis jamais
dit qui vous a le plus impressionné
oui quand à gorbatchev en face de toi
c'est impressionnant au brad pitt ou où
des gens comme ça mais en fait ils
impressionnent
franchement il n'impressionne pas plus
les un juge comme un dentiste qui soigne
des dents ils viennent ils s'assoient
j'leur reçu un élan ils sont bons jeux
mais pas beaucoup d'affect lan enfin
jeunes gens en tous les cas les peu
importe l'invité jeudi radio il faut
tous bien les traiter des invités faut
tout s'intéresser à eux parce que le
moment où tu t'intéresses à eux le
moment où tu les interviews ils doivent
être pour toi en fait d'avoir le
sentiment d'être la personne la plus
importante du monde évidemment
donc il n'ya pas de différence en fait
oui madame je vous ai vus être
extrêmement ému lors d'une interview de
michel legrand et mâcha méril
oui c'est vrai je vous ai vus avant la
larme à l'oeil je pense pas que là vous
étiez en train d'y jouer
non pas du tout c'est vrai que cette
émission c'est vrai que 7,7 nous c'est
une chose que je faisais pas avant je le
faisais un petit peu dans tout le monde
en parle mais pas très souvent et dans
salut les terriens donc effectivement à
la fin il ya des gens qui ont une
histoire
ça peut être des gens connus comme macha
méril et michel le vent ça peut être des
anonymes
je rappelle souvent que dans cette
émission celui qui a la plus longue
interview celle anonyme
et donc j'étais c'est vrai que dans
cette partie de l'émission c'est l'âge
aussi dense et je deviens plus humain
finalement il y avait un coeur sous le
costume en fait lâché prise
oui je vis l'histoire je vis l'histoire
et c'est vrai enfin pour ceux qui
connaissent pas l'histoire de michel
lebrun à jamais c'est comme des gens qui
sont connus il ya 50 ans sur une plage à
copacabana
ils ont vécu trois jours d'amour fou
sans consommer ensuite la vie les a
séparés pendant 50 ans et ils sont
mariées elles à 74 et lui 80 dont moi ça
me colle là je peux rien dire je vais
plus loin
et justement je voulais savoir est-ce
que c'est pas le meilleur moment pour
quelqu'un qui interviewent le moment où
il est cueilli par là oui vous avez
raison c'est vrai que ces moments là
sont des grands moments
alors on a on pourrait dire ouais il
pleure mais enfin quand je suis au
montage le lendemain le vendredi je re
pleurs et quand je regarde l'émission
avec ma femme le samedi je re pleure
encore une fois ci c'était ce que je
veux dire c'est que si c'était du cinéma
je pleure avec une fois et c'est vrai
que souvent le samedi je travaillais
comme ça parce qu'il ya des histoires
qui sont extrêmement touchante
merci mais ça ça c'est moi vous savez je
vais vous dire une chose madame la
télévision peut vous isoler du monde
vous pouvez devenir comme les gens
encore un peu de succès - moi j'étais
banques et reese et j'ai été refermé sur
moi même avant de faire de la télé la
télé m'a ouvert sur le monde c'est
l'effet inverse
ça m'a pas isolée du monde ça m'a fait
connaître le monde comme je suis payé
pour rencontrer des gens je les
rencontre discute avec eux sinon je
ferai peut-être pas comme les dîners 16
mars 2002 six mois après le 11 septembre
thierry meyssan non mais c'est important
pour parler de l'art de linthal chez moi
j'assume
j'assume tous mes péchés et quand j'ai
fait mon autobiographie je me souviens
que l'éditeur avait m'avait dit mais un
peu des échecs dedans parce que là ça
met un peu des succès pardon ça fait
vraiment un bouquin de losers donc moi
je me complais autant dans l'échec dans
le succès j'ai un côté morbide et donc
qui rit mais samba oui tout le monde
connaît l'histoire donc c'est le mec qui
racontait qu'il ait pas eu d'avion dans
le pentagone
nous regardons regarde puis comme ça on
juger c'est ce qui a marché ou pas
marché ce qui s'est passé thierry
blessure donc dans la version officielle
on nous raconte que un boeing 757
s'allongea énorme arrive devant le
pentagone descend juste devant le
bâtiment sur une pelouse qui se trouve à
l'avant frappe cette pelouse rebondi
touche la façade s'engouffre dans la
façade au niveau du rez de chaussée du
premier étage est totalement happé à
l'intérieur du bâtiment et brûle à
l'intérieur ça c'est ce qu'on nous
raconte maintenant n'importe qui peut
regarder la photo qui sur la couverture
du livre qu'est la photo da société de
presse qu est la première photo qu'on
est prise après l'attentât donc dans sur
la partie gauche de la photo vous avez
de la fumée au bas de la fumée vous avez
gâché par cette fumée un trou qui est
censé être celui qui a absorbé un boeing
donc c'est pas bien difficile de
comprendre que ce n'est pas possible
ouais et puis en plus bizarre qu'un
avion se soit planté horizontalement
dans une façade qui fait 24 mètres de
haut voilà parce que si vous deviez
attaquer le pentagone en avion tomberiez
en piqué sur le pentagone ces bâtiments
le plat abonde effectivement je dire à
thème et parce qu'on en a discuté
erreurs et redon erreurs dont personne
ne se remettrait j'ai eu de la chance de
m'en remettre
faute professionnelle c'est à dire que
déjà je n'avais pas fait attention que
le bouquin était publié chez un éditeur
qui n'existaient pas pas qu'il était un
éditeur que personne ne connaissait en
tous les cas bon personne dans la
production ne s'en était aperçu non plus
donc je fais cette interview en ayant
préparé pas assez clairement pas assez
en étant à l'époque dans tout le monde
en parle et les quatorze invité et je
faisais une quotidienne s'appelait
rideau à 13 gauche où il y en avait cinq
par semaine des vins invité par semaine
donc je suis arrivée là j'étais pas ce
n'est pas assez préparée et je suis
tombé c'est là où j'ai joué de malchance
les invités ce soir là était bruno solo
et yvan le bolloc'h sûr que si mes
invités avaient été bernard henri lévy
et andré glucksmann il me l'aurait dit
tout de suite que ces failles mans et
tout de suite dit il ya quelqu'un d'un
peu plus là on était là comme 3 connaît
en train de se dire [ __ ] cette
terrible histoire c'est dingue
il n'ya pas d'avion un pentagone [ __ ]
c'est fou comme trois connards quoi et
ça a quand même été diffusée dans ce qui
veut bien dire que personne sont été
personne m'a vraiment rien reprocher
puisque ça a été diffusée et ce gars là
a été invité sur canal sur france 3 et
sur toutes les chaînes mais bon j'avais
été le premier à l'interviewer je
n'avais pas pris assez de précautions
oratoires moi je prends jamais de
précautions oratoires parce que je
considère que quand on prend les
téléspectateurs pour des gens adultes
donc je ne fais jamais de précautions
oratoires je dis pas maintenant je vais
recevoir quelqu'un vous allez peut-être
penser qu'il ya un achat jamais
mireille dumas faisait ça moi je le fais
pas tu veux quand je vois quand je
présente quelqu'un dans une émission
je pense que les spectateurs vont se
faire un jugement sur lui voilà donc là
j'avais pris comme d'habitude 0
précautions oratoires sauf que ce que le
mcs raconter c'est quand même énorme
donc je me suis fait effectivement et
c'est normal je me suis je me le suis
fait reprocher il ça a été une une faute
professionnelle
et s'il ya des questions d'autres
questions parce qu'on peut aller là bas
il a peut-être ici bonsoir
bon cela vous avez porté plein d'idées à
l'écran la démission quel regard vous
avez sur les émissions qui reprennent
clairement vos concepts ou qui s'en
inspirent il y avait une petite
embrouille avec elles sont à sublet ou
même vous avez pas évoquer la suite avec
de paris dernière
quel regard vous portez sur ces mais si
vous voulez moi mon mon gagne pain
depuis l'âge de 19 ans je suis arrivé
ici j'avais 19 ans je connaissais
personne
mon gagne pain ça a été mes idées donc
je protège mes idées comme un paysan
protège son champ j'ai planté sur un
champ qui nous appartient pas le
propriétaire voilà non moi je considère
que la propriété artistique c'est
quelque chose qui existe bon après la
seule fois où je me suis vraiment énervé
parce que quand ils sont ma sublet a
fait un dîner sur france 5
j'ai rien dit bon en là où je me suis
énervé c'est à l'époque qu'en france 3 a
fait la même émission que moi la veille
avec marc olivier fogiel je trouve ça
malhonnête de la part de la direction du
groupe france télévisions de faire la
même émission que moi la veille
voilà simplement à l'époque j'ai pas eu
le courage de m'en prendre la direction
de france télévisions je m'en suis plus
fait à marc olivier fogiel qui étaient
complices mais voilà donc c'est vrai que
je considère que la propriété artistique
ça existe et les gens on parle ans après
bon il ya présente des interviews
formater mon les gens font des blind
test les gens font que j'ai fait j'ai
apporté le blind test la télévision je
peux pas interdire arthur de faire des
blagues thèse dire par là faut pas
devenir fou il ya une différence entre
faire une interview formaté faire un
blind test de temps en temps et vous
piquez carrément le concept d'une
mission mais je revendique eux ça je
sais que ça m'a été reproché parce que
moi quand je suis arrivé à la télé
c'était c'était le rtf venait de se
terminer et les gens qui travaillaient à
la télé à l'époque de la rtf toutes les
idées qui trouvaient leur appartenait
pas elle appartenait à la rtf donc le
mec que des gens qui ont inventé des
grandes émissions ils n'ont jamais
touché un centime sa partenaire la rtf
nous on est arrivé dans une autre époque
puisque ça a été l'époque 1986
des premières chaînes commerciales des
premières sociétés de production donc là
on est rentré dans un business est dans
le business ont les idées ça se protège
de savoir s'il va encore place à
l'improvisation
par exemple ce soir aussi visiblement
vous avez préparer l'interview
enfin le voilà cet entretien qui est
passionnant par ailleurs mais est-ce que
ce que vos émissions est ce qu'il ya des
morceaux encore en direct quand y'a des
disons que quand il ya des moments quand
il ya des moments d'improvisation
intéressant on va pas les couper au
montage
maintenant après une question durée
quand je faisais tout le monde en parle
c'est une émission qui durait soit deux
heures et demie soit 2h15 soit 14h45
soit trois heures puisque après c'était
la nuit
donc on faisait ce qu'on voulait donc en
laurent baffie voyez un pot de peinture
et qui commençait à repeindre le plateau
je disais loisirs pas le plateau
aujourd'hui je suis dans une émission en
access prime time
on peut pas débordé on est obligé de
faire la durée j'ai de faire une heure
donc ce genre de contraintes
évidemment ce genre de contraintes
malheureusement nuit aux parties
improvisées et c'est vrai que l'
avantage d'un show de nuit c'est que
vous pouvez beaucoup plus improvisées
tel jeu rebondit sur la question c'est à
dire avant justement sur le direct et
l'enregistrer qu'est ce que ça a ajouté
oui moi j'étais un des premiers à faire
des talk-shows monter quand je suis
arrivé à la télévision et plein de trucs
n'était pas comme maintenant vous vous
en souvenez pas mais déjà il y avait 1
on a parlé des lumières dont il y avait
des grills s'était éclairée comme chez
carrefour il y avait un langage de la
télévision dire que les gens avaient un
langage comme les politiques aussi à
l'époque avait un langage politique
avait un langage de la télévision moi
j'ai fais partie c'est un des premiers à
employer les mots tous les jours à la
télévision et à parler de sujets dont
les gens parlaient et par exemple à la
télé quand je suis arrivé on parlait
jamais de saic jamais de drogue par
exemple complètement impensable
et puis les talk shows étaient tous en
direct
et moi j'ai dit mais pourquoi quel
intérêt il a fait un journal télévisé on
peut le faire en direct oui mais un talk
show il ya aucune raison de le faire en
direct puisque il n'y a pas d'enjeu
donc on a commencé à faire des tokyo
montait alors à l'époque tout le monde
me l'a reproché en disant oui mais ils
coupent des trucs et les gens qui me le
reprocher d'ailleurs souvent c'était des
journalistes de presse écrite qui venait
l'interviewer qui mettaient leur
magnétophone en marche qui laissait
tourner le magnéto fans pendant une
heure et qui gardait ce qu'ils avaient
envie de garder évidemment
et ces gens là me reprocher de faire la
même chose à la télévision aujourd'hui
ça s'est calmé
tous les talk shows sont montés à
commencer par drucker qui a dit ardisson
rose tout sauf le direct mais lui il
fait un talk show qu'il enregistre le
mercredi qui diffuse le dimanche en tout
les talk shows sont montés sauf celui
d'alexandra sublet je crois qu'en ce
moment c'est le seul seul tokyo qui est
en direct c'est celui d'alexandra sublet
bon je crois qu'il ya aucune n'y a
aucune contre-indication à monter les
talk shows comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est un spectacle et si pour le
spectacle ce qui compte c'est le
spectacle qui compte c'est ce qu'on
donne aux téléspectateurs et il ya en
coupe quand c'est chiant en coupe quand
les invités sont chiants et ils sont
ravis en général parce qu on les rend
intéressant - souvent les invités qui me
disent mais je serai jamais aussi bien
que machin la semaine dernière je suis
rassure toi et tes pas très bien mais
quand on a enlevé les conneries qui
disait ça devient bien donc
le montage a du sens vont sortir y ont
soit alexandre je voulais savoir vous
êtes un grand curieux vous avez
interviewé tous types de profils
est-ce que vous amusez plus qu'un
certain profil est ce que c'est les
politiques qui vous font plus marrer est
ce que c'est les comédiens
les humoristes je ne sais pas à l'école
saint john yoo d'ailleurs way dont les
comme les politiques sont rarement
marrant en même temps vous en asie tu en
es ce que c'est pas ça qui est drôle
justement de oui les faire chier oui
parce que pour jouer un peu quoi quand
vous voulez quand vous voulez avoir
l'air impertinent il faut prendre
quelqu'un qui effectivement est
extrêmement respectée parce que plus la
personne est important qu'on ferme
balladur plus la personne est importante
et se donne des airs de respectabilité
plus c'est marrant de la faire chier
sauf que maintenant les politiques en ce
moment on n'invite pas parce que les
gens ne veulent plus les voir et on les
comprend donc il ya de moins en moins de
politique il ya de moins en moins de
plaisir
les comédiens sont pas marrant les
comédiens sont rarement marrant ils sont
marrant quand ils ont des bons dialogues
dans leurs films mais dans la vraie vie
sont pas tellement marrant dans les
plumes ans et effectivement les
humoristes moi quand j'invite mathieu
madénian je suis pété de rire des mecs
qui viennent que pour le fun que pour se
marrer quoi c'est ce que je préfère mais
d'en sortir un disque gai pour rebondir
par rapport à la question précédente
j'aurais voulu savoir quels sont les
interviews parce que vous avez fait
énormément qu'ils ont le plus marqué un
titre personnel et aussi je voulais
savoir s'il ya eu des rendez vous
manqués des gens que vous auriez
absolument voulu interviewer disons
jamais interview john lennon donc ça me
fait beaucoup de peine c'est fini je
l'intégrerai gérer non les interviews
vous savez effectivement quand vous
interviewer un jour j'ai interviewé en
même temps brad pitt matt damon et de
hunted elle les trois en même temps si
sûr ça vous met un peu la pression quoi
mais impressionné franchement c'est pas
de la frime un impressionné non même
quand gorbatchev qui est le mec le plus
énorme que j'ai interviewés ça m'a pas
mis au contraire je vais faire ça parce
qu'à l'époque je leur faisais faire ça
on a ça l'idée c'était gorbatchev face
comme tout le monde qu'ils fassent ça au
mans de la pub quoi mais un prêt non
c'est pas du tout de la attendant le
sepa de la froideur
c'est pas un genre que je me donne ses
juges que je les interviews c'est mon
travail des interviews mais c'est quand
même là d'un métier j'ai une autre
question en fait vous parlez de
gorbatchev et on vous a souvent reproché
d'avoir surtout à l'époque de tout le
monde en parle d'avoir mis sur le même
plan une actrice de x est un politique
est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est vrai je pense que le
principe de il ya deux comme j'ai 18 ans
a deux sortes de tokyo le one to one
comme font les américains et puis le
talk-show généraliste qui existent pas
tellement dans le monde derrière moi
j'ai vendu dans deux trois pays la
formule parce que ça n'existe pas
tellement sur un talk show à la fin de
la soirée vous êtes 10 autour de 10
autour de la tap ce ça existe pas
tellement le principe d'un talk-show
généralistes c'est un dîner de têtes ce
qu'on appelle dans les années 30 est le
principe du bon dîner de têtes c'était
une [ __ ] archevêque on retrouve dans
la littérature française des années 30
toujours cette expression une [ __ ]
marshall c'est un très bon exemple dire
qu'en fait si vous voulez par exemple
quand je recevais des écrivains dans
tout le monde en parle les gens ils ont
pas en ville samedi soir de se taper des
écrivains en même temps s'ils savent que
l'interview de l'écrivain elle est
montée
s'ils savent qu'elle va durer douze
minutes et si avant il ya une bimbo et
après un comique
ils vont regarder l'interview de
l'écrivain et je pense est un mets grand
combat que je pense que le service
public alors j'ai quand même passé 18
ans de ma vie je pense que le service
public se trompe complètement en voulant
faire des passes que dans les
républiques aujourd'hui vous avez des
émissions culturelles chiante que
personne ne regarde et des émissions qui
n'ont aucune place qui sont
divertissantes mais qui n'ont aucune
place sur le service public compte tenu
du fait s'est payée par la redevance
je pense que le briefing qu'il faudrait
donner à tous les producteurs du service
public c mettez de la culture dans tous
vos programmes
vous faites un jeu il faut quand quand
on l'a vu on en retire quelque chose
vous faites des variétés pareil quelles
que soient les missions du service
public
il devrait y avoir à l'intérieur une
dose de culture et je pense si vous
voulez que le boulot des concessions
services publics le bruit c'était de
spectacularité la culture c'est à dire
grâce à des artifices de lumière de
musique d'invités sexy et c'est de faire
passer la pilule je me rattrape pas les
mouches avec du vinaigre de faire passer
la pilule et quand j'avais des gens
comme bret easton ellis août aux mouches
ou michel houellebecq
l'audience ne baissait pas parce que les
gens disaient pas au [ __ ] et aux
helvètes je vais me coucher
non il savait qu'après hoebeke d'abord
ils découvraient quoi le bec pouvait
être intéressant jeu disons le et s'ils
connaissaient pas houellebecq
s'intéresser à houellebecq par exemple
mais il savait que derrière ça allait
redevenir marrant donc il regardait
voilà moi je suis partisan de de donner
là la culture à petites doses et dans
une ambiance sympathique sinon les gens
sinon d'avoir une dichotomie entre d'un
côté les gens cultivés l'autre côté les
gens corps 11 0 culture je rebondis je
te pose juste une question de du coup de
journaliste est ce que tu es ce que tu
ce qu'on peut interviewé tout le monde
est ce que tu t'autorise est ce qu'il ya
des personnalités que tu ne voudrais
jamais interviewé je pense notamment à
cette femme en burqa français avec josé
bové
non non c'était avec copé avec copé ben
non moi je pense que pourquoi pas moi je
pense que bon cette femme portait une
burka effectivement ça m'intéressait de
savoir pourquoi on s'habille comme ça
qu'est-ce que je pense que non moi je
porte pas de jugement en fait sur les
gens à ce niveau là quoi je dirais je
tout le monde comme disait andy warhol
tout le monde mérite son quart d'heure
de célébrité et tout le monde a droit à
un quart d'heure pour au moins pour
s'exprimer
ça m'a jamais choqué d'intéresser non
j'ai même d'interviewer un un mec je me
suis dans tout le monde en parle qui
était un copain de maurice papon
non il faut interviewé tout le monde
c'est comme un avocat il doit défendre
tout le monde n'est pas de bonjour
messieurs bonjour vous avez beaucoup
apporté à l'interview télé comme on l'a
vu vous avez réinventer en quelque sorte
la l'interview télé quels conseils
donneriez vous aux jeunes pour qu'ils
continuent à innover à réinventer
justement cette télé sans tomber dans la
dans l'interview soupe
voilà je pense 20 si j'avais un seul
conseil à donner jeudi un petit peu tout
à l'heure c'est que en fait il faut tout
savoir de la personne que vous allez
interviewer tout dire que moi par
exemple je vois très bien
des mecs qui vient de m'interviewer
duffy qui vient d'interviewer il y alors
qu'elle vit 1 1
racontez-moi votre vie non on va pas
avoir le temps tu dire qu'il faut
arriver avec des questions il faut tout
savoir et un conseil pratique parce que
c'est tout ça c'est des conseils
pratiques
il faut éviter les questions ouvertes si
vous dites à quelqu'un
l'amour pour vous c'est quoi ne vous
étonnez pas de prendre dix minutes de
blabla bla qui en général veut rien dire
si vous dites à quelqu'un qu'elle
dernière personne que tu es mais quelle
est la première personne que tu aimes
etc et la personne tels plus aimé que la
zone tels moyens mais si vous allez dans
de la question fermée
vous avez des réponses donc ce que je
dirais c'est tout savoir sur la personne
qu'on va interviewer pour le comme je te
l'heure pour l'épater pour que le mec se
disent oh [ __ ] j'ai pas intérêt à lui
raconter de conneries lui s'y connaît
donc ça c'est très important et ensuite
posé des questions précises en attendant
des réponses précises et pas être dans
le général parce que moi quand je vois
laurent delahousse sur france 2 qui dit
à quelqu'un qui a fait un film
quelle expérience a dû être ce film oui
d'accord vous êtes bien entendu avec le
reste de l'équipe
ouais
voilà il faut être précis et excusez moi
je peux rebondir quand je vous en prie
messieurs et en termes de concept
interio est ce que vous pensez qu'on a
encore et encore plein de choses à
inventer d'un verre je pense
qu'aujourd'hui - y'a un truc qui me fait
marrer en ce moment c'est tout ce qui se
passe évidemment les réseaux sociaux les
nouvelles technologies les applications
et tout ça je pense mais je le ferai pas
parce que j'ai quand même un moment mais
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
inventer autour de tout ce qui est
numérique
je sais pas quoi mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à inventer
en tous les cas là dessus ça c'est un
truc que nous on n'avait pas quand je
racontais tout à l'heure canola et voit
son audience pendant son direct c'est un
truc inimaginable quoi donc il faut je
pense qu'il faut vraiment s'intéresser
dans les nouvelles technologies dans les
nouvelles applis il doit y avoir des
moyens de trouver des idées pour les
interviews ça ah oui je vous voilà c'est
dit alors justement ma question va
rebondir sur ce qui a juste été dit
avant on vous a vu récemment être
remplacé par un robot qui avez votre
voix pour les 30 ans de canal+ et moi je
voulais savoir si en dehors de la bonne
blague
est ce que c'était un parti pris de
votre part est quelque chose que vous
pensiez qu'on allait vers une
robotisation justement du métier
pourquoi pas de présentateur télé non
non je crois pas je crois que non je
crois pas non j'étais marrant parce que
les pour les 30 ans de canal je trouvais
ça marrant de faire dans 30 ans mais je
pense que dans trente ans les robots ne
rompt pas remplacer les animateurs en
même temps c'est vrai que ce robot de
petits robots
il est hyper sophistiqués ils commencent
par exemple ce qu'on a fait samedi
dernier
il commence à pouvoir tenir une
conversation presque avec l'invité donc
je pense que ce qui va s'améliorer c'est
ça sert nous c'est encore un peu
laborieuse c'est à dire que entre le
moment entre deux phrases il faut un
petit temps mais je pense que tout ça va
vite très vite on pourra se marrer oui
monsieur poser la question de savoir ce
qu'on peut faire comme interview je
pense que déjà faire faire des
interviews par des robots ce sera très
rigolo
donc ça correspondait pas forcément une
critique non plus de votes pas non non
non c'est juste pour le fun a moins et
justement on vous y voit aussi toujours
assez en forme je dirais oui
et vous est-ce que vous vous voyez
justement dans quelques années on va
dire est ce que vous voyez parmi ces
nouvelles innovations dont vous parliez
à ce que vous voyez comme précurseur là
dessus comme google qui va qui va
transplantés le le contenu du cerveau
des gens sur des disques durs et qui va
refaire les dons qu'on sait en fait un
être humain ça sera un disque dur sur un
robot non moi je me vois franchement
aujourd'hui je m'occupe beaucoup de
fictions la seule chose qui pourrait
m'intéresser en télévision dans les
années qui viennent s'y diriger une
boîte de création avec des auteurs et
des concepteurs pour inventer des
nouveaux forme c'est un truc qui me
ferait vraiment marrer mais bon ce qu'il
faut savoir si je vais vous dire un truc
à vous faire flipper puisse vous êtes
tous français quand vous arrivez dans
une chaîne de télé avec une émission qui
a été inventé en france il ya beaucoup
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à vendre
que si elle avait été inventé aux états
unis ou en angleterre
moi j'ai un jeu qui est formidable les
associés m'ont dit on va pas le vent dit
pourquoi parce que c'est français ça n'a
pas existé ailleurs avant et la france
est un pays aujourd'hui on achète des
émissions quand elles ont été faites à
l'étranger ce qui est assez triste pour
un pays comme la france ne pas même
inventé deux trois conneries quoi alors
est-ce qu'il ya quelques autres question
bonjour à vous évoquez la fiction
justement monde est ce que vous croyez
encore à la télévision où est ce que les
activités de producteur vous avez depuis
quelques années déjà je crois pour le
cinéma et plus récemment la série c'est
vraiment vous réorienter vers quelque
chose que un comédien une activité qui a
encore durable qui vous paraît plus
durable que la télévision d'annoncer
qu'elle existe encore c'est pas ça c'est
que quand j'arrêterai de faire de
l'animation dix ans j'aurais même je
fasse quelque chose ou quelqu'un de très
actif et il me semble que la fiction il
sera plus adapté
dans quelques années que l'animation
maintenant quand j'ai commencé la
fiction il ya cinq ans je me suis dit je
vais arrêter de faire de la télé je vais
faire que de la fiction est en fait le
kiff de faire de la télé en fait je
trouve que j'ai plus envie m'arrêter
j'ai envie de continuer parce que je
trouve que quand on arrive sur le
plateau le jeudi soir il ya une espèce
d'atmosphère
il ya un côté très ludique qui est très
agréable
maintenant l'avenir de la télé je pense
que la télé a énormément d'avenir je
pense pas dès je pense pas du tout que
les gens regardent la tv trois heures et
demie par jour
je crois que la fois encore augmenter
cette année
donc les gens qui disent que la télé va
être même la radio est toujours là quand
on a eu les sondages radio
cette semaine c'est un événement
national que laurent ruquier réussi et
kanu n'avait pas réussi sur europe 1 la
radio est toujours là la presse écrite
sera toujours là parce que la presse
écrite de toute façon vous pouvez avoir
4 4 articles sur internet
celui qui compte c'est celui qui est
dans du quai sur du papier c'est comme
ça c'est la culture de ce pays et la
télé liant sera jamais su planter donc
dans la télé moi ça m'intéresse toujours
en temps en tant qu'animateur ça
m'intéresse toujours en tant que
producteur à terme je vais effectivement
dirigé vers les séries et vers le cinéma
je suis en train de le faire oui c'est
le seul truc que j'avais pas fait
c'était de la fiction oui tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que la plupart dotés
spectateurs étaient plus français mais
en fait moi je viens de l'afrique je
sais que canal+ et beaucoup suivi au
travers de son bouquet canalsat par
rapport à vos choix et les critères de
vos invités
est-ce que vous avez aussi pensé à
inviter deux acteurs politiques ou
musicales ou de musiciens ou des
artistes africains parler autour des
questions internationales aussi je veux
savoir sur quelles questions vous partez
je sais que c'est la proximité c'est
d'abord la france mais votre émission et
internationales donc voilà elle et elle
est légèrement international sûr que
quand je travaillais sur france
télévisions sur france 2 il ya une
chaîne qui s'appelle tv5 monde et c'est
vrai que l'émission tout le monde en
parle et est visible dans beaucoup de
régions du monde
des fois j'allais au bout du monde en
vacances et je tombais sur générale
comment ça va être drôle d'effet canal
c'est quand même pas ça il ya deux cent
mille abonnés en afrique
je pense pas qu'ils regardent tous salut
les terriens et nous leur peau est
claire on travaille à 100% pour le
marché français
maintenant c'est marrant vous disiez ça
parce que j'ai rencontré quelqu'un ce
matin qui fait de la télévision pour
canal afrique et qui m'a demandé de
réfléchir à des émissions pour canal
afrique et sami m'intéresse beaucoup
effectivement à partir de l'afrique je
vous suivez et donc voilà ça m'intéresse
je vais je vais travailler avec merci
bonsoir moi je voulais vous demander ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous pensez
des animateurs qui cumule de nombreuses
émissions pense à cyril hanouna nagui ou
christina cordula encore vous n'avez
qu'une émission d'une heure est ce que
c'est parce que vous êtes feignant nom
alors je vais vous dire la vérité
j'aimerais être un peu plus fainéants
dans la vérité c'est quand je suis
arrivé à canal plus après m'être fait
virer de france 2 le mec qui m'a virait
sébastien milhau en disant que c'était
malhonnête de travailler sur paris
première en même temps question
d'honnêteté je crois qu'on a vu avec
bygmalion qu'il n'a pas ne l'avait pas
de leçons à me donner donc en fait si
vous voulez j'ai tout de suite dit aux
gens d'utiliser le grand journal en 10
ans quel que soit les rumeurs que vous
entendez entendiez je ne veux pas faire
le grand journal on va venir vous dire
or 10 en argent non dès le début j'ai
choisi la fiction
donc en fait je fais une émission d'une
heure parce que le reste de la semaine
je m'occupe
de mes séries de mes films et dieu sait
si c'est compliqué mais si temps pour
répondre à votre question je pense que
oui ce que je racontais tout à l'heure
sur thierry meyssan est la preuve
évidente qu à un moment j'avais quatorze
invité dans tout le monde en parle et
cinq ans et vos attributs ça faisait 2
à un moment je me suis planté vous avez
vu le plantage mans donc ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il faudrait être
raisonnable et c'est vrai que mon
émission du samedi sur canal
elle durait une heure et demie au lieu
de durer une heure ça me ferait beaucoup
plaisir ce serait mieux pour l'émission
média à faire des émissions tous les
jours non je préfère en faire une bien
chaque semaine on va on va si vous
voulez bien comme vous voulez est ce que
tu me donne l'autorisation de faire un
truc que je moi je peux jamais faire du
coup en tant que journaliste sur une
chaîne d'info de de faire une interview
formaté que j'étais préparée est ce que
c'est une interview monstre sacré
monstre sacré est ce que comme les
monstres sacrés de la télé tu déteste
qu'on déteste
non moi j'aime bien comme des tests en
fait les gens de lettres et mais moi
j'aime j'adore être aimé mais s'il ya
des gens qui me détestent ça me dérange
pas je vis très bien en sachant qu'il ya
des gens qui me détestent ça ne dérange
pas voilà j'ai pas besoin d'être copain
et tout le monde pour bien dormir est ce
que comme les monstres sacrés de la télé
tu visionnent t best of la nuit quand il
fait des insomnies non mais en revanche
tout le monde en parle je le regardais
pas parce que ç'a duré très longtemps
c'était fatigant je me fais un plaisir
de regarder non pas mais best-of mon
cher flanc je me fais un plaisir de
regarder
salut les terriens avec ma femme tous
les samedis et c'est pas drôle parce
qu'elle me fait me l'as tu aurais pu
mettre une photo là tu aurais pu
m'atteindre
est ce que comme les monstres sacrés de
la tellette à un coach un chauffeur de
gardes du corps six assistantes une
masseuse
non j'ai un coach heureusement oui enfin
j'ai une mine coach qui me fait courir
parce que voilà il faut être en forme
moi je pense que j'avais pas fait j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que la télévision
m'avait ouvert sur le monde
ce qui est tout à fait vrai et la
télévision mais doit pas être trop
décrépis c'est à dire que la télé mais
oblige quand même être un minimum en
forme sinon je pense que franchement je
ferai pas télé je serai plus gros est ce
que comme les monstres sacrés la télé tu
as déjà tous claqué tout claqué comme
argent j'en ai pas beaucoup moi j'ai pas
contrairement à deux mecs comme de la
rue où arthur confédération de arthur
une vraie fortune jeu de quoi vivre mais
j'ai franchement j'ai pas j'ai jamais
sacrifié en c'est marrant parce que j'ai
toujours choisi de faire ce que je
voulais faire
quand je faisais de la pub je gagne
beaucoup d'argent j'ai décidé de faire
de la télé ou des barges gagner rien
quand je fais du cinéma apparaît en fait
je mon argent finance
mes envies mais c'est pas dans le but de
thésauriser est d'être le plus riche du
cimetière non pour à tour est ce que
comme les monstres sacrés la télé est
arrivé de manger le dimanche midi à
neuilly avec nicolas sarkozy
non alors ça c'est un conseil que je
donne à tous nos amis j'ai déjà dit mais
c'est il faut surtout pas devenir
copains avec eux surtout pas c'est la
fin du monde si on est copain avec après
vous à peine avant l'interview de jean
bon on fait comme on habille donc pas de
pas de rapport et nicolas sarkozy joue
pas plus nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande personnes est ce que comme les
monstres sacrés la télé tu aurais jamais
pu réussir aussi longtemps et aussi bien
sans de drogués à la la la drogue
donc j'ai dit samedi j'ai invité
l'ancien propriétaire des bains douches
qui a pris 6 grammes de coke pendant
trente ans donc j'ai montré ce que
c'était j'ai expliqué à la fin de
l'émission ne fallait pas en prendre
enfin la cocaïne n'était pas une drogue
récréative qui ça détruisait le cerveau
maintenant faut dire les choses puisque
j'ai du mal à mentir j'ai du mal à faire
la langue de bois moi c'est vrai que
quand on a des idées à trouver
un bon pétard c'est désinhibe c'est
désinhibe parce que d'un seul coup vous
quittez un peu la pression de
l'environnement quotidien vous planez un
peu voilà et ça peut aider nommage
raison mon slogan de pub le plus connu
c'est la paire rien n'a pas deux mains
une phrase définitive je les trouve en
fumé un pétard dans ma baignoire je peux
dire le contraire tu voulais il faut pas
faire la promotion de la drogue je pense
que quelqu'un qui est feignants et qui
fument des pétards et va devenir encore
plus feignants etc
je pense pas que la drogue soins bien
mais quand on contrôle et quand on se
sert de la drogue pour des raisons
créatives et non pas uniquement
récréative
non mais c'est vrai le un pétard ça fait
venir elle est dernière est ce que comme
les monstres sacrés la télé tu détestes
cette nouvelle génération de
journalistes blonds gominés genre gendre
idéal qui allient leurs promoteurs comme
des robots sur les chaînes d'info
continue
non je pense que les les les gens qui
ont connu 68 cette génération qui veut
pas s'en aller cette génération qui
occupent les places et qui veut pas
laisser passer les jeunes c'est vrai
qu'on avait en a eu un truc nous jeu
saints
on a connu la révolution mais c'est vrai
on a connu une époque où moi je vois
maintenant les on était contre tout cas
on était alors moi je te prends un grand
révolutionnaire assurer vos mais on
était quand même on voulait changer le
monde on voulait bon pas du tout changé
si le monde qui nous a changé mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que peut-être que
la différence c'est qu'on osait des
trucs aujourd'hui peut-être les gens
plus jeunes n'ose penser je pense que
c'est assez vrai c'est pas du tout un
reproche c'est simplement qu'on a été
élevé dans ce contexte où on a vu
arriver le rock'n'roll la drogue en
vente libre les voyages voilà mais
maintenant aujourd'hui on se retrouve à
65 verges
merci thierry ardisson
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu